et tout de suite Bruno à charreront
bonjour à vous vous êtes ingénieur en
physique nucléaire responsable du
laboratoire de la crirade Commission de
recherche d'informations indépendante
sur la radioactivité merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation de France 24 dans
le sujet qu'on vient de regarder
ensemble gouverneur de personne et
expliquer que le niveau des eaux
pouvaient monter de manière très
critique en quelques heures ce seuil
critique a-t-il été atteint au moment où
l'on se parle
alors à la criera on est plus préoccupé
sur la question de l'impact pour la
centrale de zapporisia c'est clair qui a
évidemment un impact par rapport à
l'inondation de population
en aval du barrage mais ce qu'il faut
avoir aussi en tête ce sont les
conséquences pour la centrale de
zapporiggia la centrale nucléaire elle
est située à 140 150 km plus au nord du
barrage mais elle a besoin d'être
refroidie en permanence même si les
réacteurs sont à l'arrêt le dernier a
été arrêté en septembre les combustibles
hautement radioactifs qui sont dans les
cœurs des six réacteurs de cette
centrale et aussi dans les piscines de
désactivation de chacun de ces réacteurs
ces matières hautement radioactives ont
besoin d'être refroidi en permanence et
pour refroidir est-ce qu'un réservoir
avec une certaine contenance en eau ne
peut pas prendre le relais pour
justement refroidir c'est
c'est ces réacteurs
oui alors effectivement le lot de
refroidissement est pompé dans l'immense
réservoir de carroska et ensuite elle
est acheminée vers des bassins de
rétention actuellement ces bassins de
rétention à la centrale nucléaire ont
assez d'eau mais si la fuite la brèche
dans le barrage de kaaroka conduit petit
à petit à faire baisser dramatiquement
le niveau 2 dos en amont il va y avoir
un moment où il ne sera plus possible de
d'alimenter directement en eau c'est
barrage c'est bassins de rétention et là
la question qui va se poser c'est est-ce
que l'exploitant de la centrale
nucléaire trouvera des solutions
opérationnelles pour faire un complément
d'eau sinon il y a vraiment risque
d'échauffement du combustible irradier
dans certaines ces réacteurs
de la centrale Bruno chariron fait
allusion à qui on sait que cette zone
est sous contrôle sous occupation russe
qui peut intervenir pour tenter de
réparer
sur le site alors c'est bien tout ce qui
fait que cette situation de la centrale
de zaporigia est particulièrement
préoccupante c'est que le contrôle de la
centrale nucléaire est aujourd'hui
assumée par les Russes et en même temps
l'exploitant
ukrainien et ergoatome continue à en
être en partie responsable la situation
est donc particulièrement compliquée il
faut savoir vous le savez que les
personnels de cette centrale vivent sous
pression depuis que la centrale a été
envahie ça fait maintenant plus d'un an
il y a la moitié au moins du personnel
qui a quitté cette zone donc il y a un
souci sur la compétence opérationnelle
des personnels de la centrale la
gouvernance dans cette centrale puisque
c'est devenu très compliqué et pour
faire face évidemment à des situations
critiques comme celle là c'est beaucoup
plus difficile donc la sûreté nucléaire
de la centrale des aporidgia et de plus
en plus mis à mal depuis le début du
conflit perte d'alimentation électrique
régul Ière problème sur le personnel et
maintenant se rajoute un nouveau
problème à gérer c'est la diminution du
niveau d'eau dans l'immense réservoir de
kyoska ça fait beaucoup contre la montre
est engagée au plus vite en intervient
au mieux on gère la situation
alors là on n'est pas dans la course
contre la montre au sens chaque heure
qui compte mais on est dans un problème
qu'il faut résoudre dans les jours qui
viennent il faut absolument s'assurer
que il existera en permanence un plan B
pour amener de l'eau dans les systèmes
dans les bassins de rétention de cette
centrale nucléaire deux apports la
situation elle est pas critique
immédiatement mais toutes ces événements
fragilisent chaque chaque jour
pratiquement la sûreté nucléaire de
cette centrale et c'est ça qui est
particulièrement préoccupant et très
rapidement si vous le voulez bien Bruno
charreiro est-ce qu'il y a un risque de
contamination des sols est-ce qu'il y a
un risque pour les populations civiles à
l'entour
vous voulez dire dans l'hypothèse où il
y aurait un accident nucléaire à la
centrale des aporidges oui bien sûr
parce que même si les six réacteurs sont
à l'arrêt il y a une quantité de matière
radioactive très importante dans
l'intérieur de la centrale et en cas de
perte des capacités de refroidissement
il pourrait évidemment y avoir des
rejets radioactifs tout à fait important
alors on en est pas là mais encore une
fois les marges de sûreté diminuent au
fur et à mesure que ce conflit perdure
merci beaucoup Bruno Charrin
en physique nucléaire merci d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions
à plusieurs capitales étrangères ont
réagi condamné cette attaque un crime de
guerre selon Londres même déclaration à
Berlin le chef de l'auto dénonce lui la
brutalité de cette guerre menée par la
Russie puis sachez que le président
zélinski a convoqué une réunion
d'urgence de son Conseil de sécurité il
appelle également ce que le Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies se réunissent
à son tour on retrouve tout de suite
Gulliver crack en direct de Kiev bonjour
à vous Gulliver comment est-ce qu'on a
réagi dans la capitale ukrainienne après
l'attaque de ce barrage
alors je pense avec une bonne dose de
choc et une dose aussi de colère mais
c'est quelque chose qui avait été évoqué
en octobre dernier les Ukrainiens
accusés les Russes de vouloir faire
exploser ce barrage les Russes à leur
tour avaient accusé les Ukrainiens de
faire la même chose c'est la tradition
mais en octobre quand les discussions
ont eu lieu la conclusion avait été que
cela serait vraiment une acte de folie
de la part des risques de faire cela ça
empêcherait les
l'acheminement de l'eau fraîche vers la
Crimée par le canal ça mettrait un
risque la centrale des aporisa ça
provoquerait des inondations sur des
territoires
occupés par les Russes et c'est le cas
aujourd'hui c'est plus les territoires
occupés par les Russes sur la
rive-sud-est du fleuve qui qui sont plus
à risque d'inondation mais pour les
Ukrainiens
les risques seraient encore plus
impensable en termes de la destruction
de cette centrale hydroélectrique
extrêmement importante l'inondation des
territoires aussi contrôler par
l'Ukraine tout le monde pensait que
personne n'allait oser faire ça et
pourtant la Russie semble l'avoir fait
et cela a provoqué en plus du choc et de
la colère une certaine peur je pense à
travers l'Ukraine sur jusqu'où est-ce
qu'ils sont vraiment capables d'aller
dans ces actes de destruction qui
peuvent paraître irrationnelles même de
leur point de vue alors les Ukrainiens
accusent les Russes les Russes accusent
à leur tour les Ukrainiens d'être à
l'origine de cette attaque
oui mise à part considérations
circonstancielle à qui profitent les
crimes etc je pense qu'il faut d'abord
regarder la situation sur le terrain
très concrètement comment est-ce que on
peut exploser un barrage de cette
envergure les Russes accusent les
Ukrainiens de l'avoir fait par une
frappe d'un missile de longue distance
ce serait sinon impossible extrêmement
difficile ce barrage avait déjà été
touché par des requêtes et les dommages
étaient pas du tout à l'échelle de faire
couler l'eau et de faire sauter une
grande partie du barrage en plus donc
les Ukrainiens disques cela a été fait
par des explosifs qui ont été mis sur
place et je vous rappelle c'est les
Russes qui contrôlent ces territoires
les Ukrainiens ne sont pas là donc pour
planter des explosifs sur place ou bien
il aurait fallu le faire avant le 24
février 2022 et je vois pas pourquoi les
Ukrainiens auraient fait ça ou bien
forcément c'est les Russes qui ont pu
les planter et en plus de cela dans les
premiers messages qui sortaient sur
différentes chaînes télégrammes ces
pseudomédia russe construit tous
maintenant à Kiev très attentivement les
premiers messages parlé d'explosion
provoqués par d’explosifs sur place
juste il pensait à ce moment-là que
c'était une explosion de moins de 30
Burger et que les dégâts étaient moins
de 7 ensuite qui est venu cet accusation
des risques comme quoi c'était une
frappe
ukrainienne alors là aussi on voit une
certaine confusion dans le message que
les Russes essaient de trans